I was so unhappy lonely isolated
terrified I got to a point where I
couldn't see a future and is something
that was so shameful I can't like you
know talk about it no amount of guilt
will ever change the past no amount of
anxiety can shape the future I'm not of
the belief that had I figured this out I
would have been a better performer I
just think I would have been happier
throughout my entire career
brought to you today by Roca I'm locked
20 off your order with the code richroll
roca.com
so happy to have you here man excited to
talk to you you've been on this journey
with mental health uh with body
dysmorphia with disordered eating and
you made this decision to go public with
this struggle and your recovery process
um initially through the documentary
that you made with koros which I found
to be very impactful and courageous the
level at which you were willing to be
vulnerable and I'm sure has been you
know impactful for a lot of people so
you know let's let's just start there
like laying yourself bare you know what
I mean it was terrifying I I hated it
um it and you know it's funny as as an
athlete and a dreamer I had always
kind of visualize that someday I might
make the rounds in media and you know be
on Good Morning America sit with you but
it would have been after winning UTMB or
having some big Accolade next to my name
the perfect set of circumstances yeah
and and so that's all how I always like
you know kind of wrote that story but I
think this is actually more poetic and
kind of in line with where I am at where
it kind of is a deep reminder that we're
so much more than those accomplishments
and I am I mean I'm actually really
Lindsay was asking me like are you
nervous and I said no like I'm pretty
psyched because For the First Time
in my life I'm going to give or we're
going to have a chat where I don't feel
like I'm holding this huge secret right
right yeah it's much more stressful if
you have to show up and wear this
certain mask and answer questions in a
certain way that's gonna further this
image that you're trying to project and
it's a lot more relaxing when you're
like I have nothing to hide ask me
anything and it's just whatever it is it
is yeah like you're you're not
defaulting to those like you know I
don't know perfectly crafted answers
you've pre-loaded because you know how
to dodge questions and I think it's sort
of that act of self-preservation where
you're embarrassed or shameful of
something and it's it's not that you
don't want to be honest but you don't
feel that you can right so you have the
secret life that you're trying to
basically hold like at the same time as
holding up this image right and the the
lock on that cabinet is shame yeah right
and it has uh such a powerful grip as a
motivator to you know keep things quiet
keep things private and the fear that
kind of lives behind that
drives your life yeah and I think shame
is a very powerful emotion to basically
make you I don't know kind of like
retreat from society you know you or
relationships sure yeah you isolate yeah
uh shame you know shame grows in the
dark and uh yeah you withdraw from
Humanity because it's to anxiety ridden
to you know sort of hold that mask up
and be around people it's exhausting
yeah and uh yeah so you have stepped out
into the light yeah and I think I think
that was
I mean
part of what I've learned in some of
these recovery aspects or aspects of
recovery is that I have to learn to sit
with anxiety
and not reduce it you know and I think
that's part of the like bios morphine
OCD stuff you know there are therapies
that treat you like in CBT or others
like that you want to like diminish the
anxiety and how do you like breathe
through it but in you know these
compulsive disorders you need to learn
to sit with it you know let that anxiety
course through your veins and recognize
that the fear that's causing you to
maybe do these compulsive acts isn't
actually there but like that Obsession
of the compulsion are linked through the
anxiety and so we're not trying to
remove the anxiety we're just basically
trying to acknowledge and tell it to get
the hell out of here right so so the
difference being yes with compulsive
disorders or
um addictions there is this unbelievable
drive to change your state like it's so
uncomfortable to sit with whatever
you're experiencing that you will
literally do anything to take yourself
out of that and it's on autopilot right
so whether that's through a substance or
a food or withdrawing from p people or
gambling or some kind of weird you know
obsessive compulsive Behavior it's all a
coping mechanism a defense strategy to
remove you from that discomfort and
Recovery is about as you said sitting in
it and realizing as much like because
when it comes up you literally feel like
you're gonna die right it's it's like
life-threatening and to learn that
feelings are just feelings and even
though it might feel like it's going to
kill you the one thing you can count on
with feelings is that they always change
they never stay the same and you have to
kind of build that muscle over time yep
and and even though I mean now I'm 38
and I started therapy when I was 35. I I
feel like I you know I'm an adult but
sometimes emotionally I feel like I'm
still very stunted and you know like I
remember first time in therapy like
talking about emotions like I could name
happy sad angry nervous but then like I
got this emotional wheel from my
therapist and I don't know like dozens
and dozens and dozens of you know
descriptors on there and you know just
kind of that that entire quiver of
different emotions like I just had to
never really processed or been able to
identify them and I think what you're
saying that leads to us if you can't
process your emotions we tend to either
harm ourselves or sometimes other people
in response to it and and so I think
with my through this you know through
some of the treatment I realized that
the more I spoke about it the more I
opened up to Lindsay or my family or you
know that chorus documentary which was
absolutely terrifying to do
um being someone that's afraid of other
people's opinions like that drives a lot
of my stuff like just that fear of being
made fun of or ridiculed um or not being
enough
I think that was a sort of an act of
confronting that anxiety demon of being
so afraid but recognize that I came
through it and not only was I okay like
I probably connected with more people as
a result of it sure of course I mean
that one act
I mean I had more responses like
thousands of people reaching out men
women you know people across the
Spectrum like either thinking or saying
hey I deal with these things and I mean
I I didn't have the energy to respond to
all those people so like you know I I
felt bad about that you know it was like
in in my I guess athletic life I've I've
always made it a point to like respond
to every DM or comment and you know
because I just feel grateful that
someone's taking notice but in this one
I didn't have the energy to do that and
so like part of me but I I was able to
acknowledge anybody going like hey
people don't expect a response and I
think because I've been in their shoes
where you feel seen or heard if someone
else talks and I think that was what
really
in combination with the hey this is part
of the you know part of the healing
process I also recognize if I can make
one person feel less alone then it will
all be worth it because I mean I am a
pretty like genuinely like
happy-go-lucky guy and I I love life but
I got to a point where I couldn't see a
future and
I know that's the case for a lot of
people and you feel isolated you feel
alone you feel like you're the only
person that's ever gone through this had
that thought
with that emotion and I just recognized
if my you know overcoming this fear that
I was building up in my own head
is something that was so shameful I
can't like you know talk about it then
if that can allow someone else to feel
empowered enough to go seek help or talk
to a friend or talk to their parents
then it'll all be worth it and yeah and
of course it is it is you are
experiencing that there's this you know
baked in irony because in the process of
making that film to your point I'm sure
it was terrifying and you're thinking
you're going to be judged and all your
perfectionism and OCD and and uh you
know the fear around like uh you know
external
um acceptance and all of that just
starts you know lighting up your brain
like crazy uh but ultimately you know
the connection that ultimately you're
seeking that that is the reason why
those maladaptive you know thought
patterns come up is achieved through the
vulnerability and the courage to you
know to kind of speak your truth and
that's what truly connects people right
so it's bizarre it's like everything
inside of you is saying this is the
wrong thing to do and yet ultimately it
solves the underlying problem that those
defense mechanisms are trying to protect
you uh you know against it's a very like
counter-intuitive strange thing it's
strange and I think there is a level of
I don't know if the right term for it
but almost like performative
vulnerability where you know you know
that there might be that response but I
I have found because I've engaged in
that kind of stuff over the years where
you know I might say something knowing
that like people might feel sorry for me
and then they're gonna like you know be
there to like coddle me but like
something like this I think I knew it
was
I it was so uncomfortable and I like I
knew that I was I was more in that like
you know if we had that Venn diagram
more on the side of like this is what I
need to be doing you know I don't think
vulnerability is easy I think it is hard
like and if and if it's if it's not hard
you're probably not actually being
vulnerable that's probably right like
you're you're still like you're hearing
performance vulnerability there's a lot
of that out there right yeah especially
on social media like and figuring out
how much to tell of your story or that
uh and and like everyone I have a I
don't know a challenging relationship
with social media and and I perpetuate
it because over the years I've carefully
curated the image I want to see and that
fed my by dysmorphia where I would check
in with what I posted and then if I'd
see myself in the mirror it wasn't that
exact frame that I hand selected right
where gravity was like working perfectly
to make me stride yeah and then I like
in reality I'm like that's you know that
was a hundredth of a second I was
comparing myself against my own thing so
I contributed to all of that negativity
that would just spiral in my head right
well all the incentives in your world
like line up to you know kind of make
that situation more exacerbated yeah
yeah and I think there's something
unique about
first of all like being an athlete and
suffering from this because you have to
be competitive and you have to show up
with your game face and there's some
masking that goes into how to be
competitive and and on the edge that you
want and need to be to you know be
amongst the elites but then on top of
that the bigger issue being that you're
male and I think the conversation around
eating disorders and these types of of
compulsions with women is much further
you know down the line like there's
there's not as much sort of Shame and
hiding in the conversation around how
this impacts women and girls than there
than it is with men and and I really
think that's a big reason why I think
it's so important what you're doing
um because I think this is something
that is massive and hidden among men and
you can see it beneath and behind so
much of
the diet tribalism and the nutrition
Wars that we see on social media which
you know I'm not immune from that is
this like plant-based person of course
uh but whether it's like vegan keto low
carb uh you know intermittent fasting
time restricted eating like all of these
approaches
in the kind of nanosphere are shrouded
in language around optimization and
performance but in reality I think
behind that
for a lot of people it's about weight
loss weight management it's about body
image
um and it's a way for men to kind of
hide that they're suffering from a
version of what you have endured while
looking outwards to the world as if
they're like a biohacker or something
like that when in truth there's a lot of
insecurity and shame and guilt
um because just like women men go on
Instagram and they see all these guys
with idealized you know figures and most
people don't look like that and even the
people that do look like that probably
only look like that temporarily or with
the right filter and lighting and all
the rest yeah indeed I agreed it's um I
think they're and I'm hoping this is a
generational thing that we start to see
kind of dissipate but there is that
notion of Boys Don't Cry you know and I
definitely I mean I wasn't explicitly
raised that way but I think you know
people I was around like friends and
like you know it's it's kind of you know
the undercurrent that you notice and and
I just I don't think I really had honest
conversations with anyone close to me
until I was probably in my 30s you know
it's just kind of internalized things
and I I view about anything you mean in
general like just just the emotional you
you being in touch with your emotions
and the truth of who you are yeah and I
think
part of that is I and I don't know where
it began but i s I always
thought that you know maybe you know
that was a weakness like somehow I
connected those dots and like
I was gonna just be tough I was gonna
like you know bury it swallow it you
know I could grip through anything and
you know I unfortunately do that with
injuries also where I I still get afraid
of like telling Mario I'm hurt you know
my coach and uh you know I should be
pretty that should be easy now like I've
been doing this for 20 years but like I
almost view like getting injured as as a
a weakness or it's in you know it's an
inadequacy and I'm afraid to tell people
that and I think with the emotional
stuff it was similar I I just you know
internalized everything and the more you
internalize things the more that Echo
chamber gets deeper and deeper inside
your own head and as you said earlier
you know shame and all these other you
know like emotions that we don't want to
take root they
they just feed in that darkness and I
think that unless you give voice to
these things it's easier for it to kind
of you know the ruminations to kind of
take really deep root and it's hard to
then dig those out
I want to do a little what it was like
what happened and what it's like now in
the parlance of recovery but I think it
would be helpful to first kind of Define
what we're talking about when you say
body dysmorphia or eating disorder or
OCD like what are you saying
specifically like how do you define
those
um phrases and words
also important and I'm sure you have a
really astute and uh intelligent
audience like I I have a graduate degree
in my own experience yeah you know and I
might I you know I'm a licensed physical
therapist but and a pro Runner but I am
not a psychologist so I I can speak from
my end of one
um but that's what we do in recovery
anyway right like we're here to share
our experience we're not here to
provide medical advice yeah sure and uh
and I think especially with the eating
disorder stuff it's a it's a fascinating
illness there are I mean there are a lot
of different kind of branches of it but
in general it's a competitive Disorder
so I've even found myself that I listen
to other people's recovery stories or
they you know kind of recount what
happened and my brain latches on to like
trying to find hacks of how to like
double down on what I'm dealing with and
so I I you know I try to be very careful
with the way I describe things and not
romanticize aspects too much you know
because unfortunately it is that is kind
of true to that disorder and and it's
really interesting that it um of all
mental illnesses like especially
anorexia nervosa has the highest
mortality rate of any mental illness
like even more than depression which wow
it I mean that's really powerful to
think that you know like it's like you
know because as you said earlier we all
have issues with food you know so it's
kind of like hey like oh yeah I count my
calories or or you know I'm afraid of
overeating or like that Thanksgiving
dinner did me in I you know unbuttoned
my belt and you know and so those are
normal but I think with any disorder is
when it becomes debilitating intrusive
you know all-encompassing and you it
creates so much anxiety you can't get
away from it
um but so I guess from my experience
um like eating disorders like I've I've
kind of I don't know tried on different
hats in the eating disorder uh you know
kind of uh I don't know in the in the
fashion show of Eating Disorders um like
I I had a bout in college where I was
dealing with anorexia
um I'm now actually clinically diagnosed
with ausfed which is other specified
feeding and eating disorders because the
big three yeah the big three are
anorexia nervosa
um bulimia nervosa and then binge eating
those are kind of like the three big
guys like people have heard of those um
but I think what clinicians found is
that the diagnostic Criterium in the
dcsm-5 is so specific thick to meet that
classification it was leaving a lot of
people that were suffering out and then
you can't get access to health care you
know if you don't have an app like an
inadequate diagnosis so like to say
disordered eating is sort of a catch-all
umbrella for anything else that might
fall between the cracks yeah because I
think eating disorder versus disordered
eating is is like
maybe this is a bad analogy a clinical a
clinical diagnosis versus something's
[__] up over here but yeah you don't
have a name for it yeah so and maybe
this is a bad analogy but like a binge
Drinker versus an alcoholic like okay I
went on a bender and like I displayed
some of these behaviors but you can
choose to stop you can like go on with
your life the alcoholic can't you know
so I I maybe maybe there's some sort of
parallel there but I get that so you
know with someone suffering from an
eating disorder like you know an
anorexic it's not that they don't want
to eat or they know they they can't eat
but there's something like in their
brain that's basically gone Haywire that
they aren't able to and even as they
deteriorate
um but I I base and through my
experience in the medical model like I'm
thankful that my therapist knew how to
you know I don't know not game the
system but like treat it appropriately
we were like I was probably going to get
denied because I didn't fit one of those
you know three big ones and you know for
all intensive purposes I'm a healthy
white male you know a pro athlete yeah
you're not you're not like I don't fit
the building you're not you know
stumbling in at 85 pounds with your hair
falling out yeah so you know it why
would an insurance want to pay for my
eating disorder you know treatments
um but um so I think that that's a bit
of like the you know disordered eating I
think everyone probably
experiences disordered eating at some
point you know and as you said The Fad
diets that promotes a lot of disordered
eating behaviors I think though if you
have someone that's predisposed to
developing an actual eating disorder
that's where those fad diets are
dangerous right because you can just
hide behind it yeah it's like oh I like
it and I'm intermittent fasting for 22
hours a day right actually you're just
not you're just not eating you're not
eating and you're doing it out in public
in a way where nobody can say anything
yeah uh uh but in reality what is
actually going on here right yeah right
and so how does OCD and other kind of
compulsive disorders perfectionism
people pleasing all of that like how do
these things because it's all a soup
right and on some level
you know it's the longer I've been doing
this and the longer I've kind of been in
this world like it all feels like the
same thing it just shows up in different
ways whether you're a heroin addict or
an alcoholic or a gambling addict or a
love addict there's something inside of
you something happened to you or you're
wired in a certain way where you feel
not at ease with yourself and you don't
like how you show up in the world and
it's so uncomfortable that you develop
these little things that you do to make
you feel safe and okay and often they're
about trying to regain or exercise some
level of control in in a situation in
which you feel out of control and food
you know plays a big part in that
um but really it's rooted in
a sense of feeling different than
everyone else of being insecure like you
don't measure up and you're you in and
of yourself
are not okay
yeah so how does that work and like how
do those other kind of like what is the
OCD piece and the people pleasing and
the perfectionism aspect of all of this
OCD obsessive-compulsive disorder body
dysmorphic disorder isn't I think it's
classified as an obsessive-compulsive
related Disorder so there are like two
separate things but they're kind of in
that soup of compulsive behaviors
um and from my understanding the big
difference is they share the same
basically obsessions compulsions linked
with anxiety but body dysmorphic
disorder is directly linked just to your
body where OCD has like very kind of
clear Pathways of like harm OCD or you
know germ OCD or um uh just right OCD
all these like you know religious OCD
they fall into these little little
categories and like body dysmorphia is
almost like it's just the body OCD right
I see I got it so whether you're you
know uh you know checking the lock on
your door 10 times or um you know
whatever however that shows up it's it's
it's a stress reducing anxiety reducing
kind of behavior so for like the by
dysmorphic suffer they may be checking
themselves in the mirror
and which we all do but are you checking
yourself in the mirror for hours a day
like is it impeding your ability to go
to work you know are you looking at
every reflective surface do you know you
can see your reflection in a spoon you
know and obviously a spoon is also you
know concave or convex so it's gonna
like distort it even more but you will
see yourself in a non-flattering way and
think that's real
um and so there's I mean I found that
anything that was reflective became
basically an area that I could reduce
the anxiety but the more you engage in
those compulsions the stronger the link
becomes and it just like
self-perpetuates and it gets to the
point where you don't trust yourself if
you don't do the compulsion because the
obsession is so
I don't know it's so invasive and
debilitating and unwelcomed that you
feel like you have to do the compulsion
to reassure yourself that it's okay is
that you know checking the lock over and
over or washing my hands are my hands
actually dirty
um and so with body dysmorphia it could
be checking it could be you know
fidgeting with your hair you know your
glasses making sure things are just
right
um because your fear of maybe that
rejection or the fear of other people
judging you
um and I don't know it I think like in
my family like we have a pretty
extensive history of alcoholism and so
like to what you said like I think there
are a lot of similarities between all
these things it's like and the funny
thing is the same thing that you just
found a different way of expressing I
mean it's kind of funny like in so I I
I've had a really really difficult
relationship with food
um for a lot of reasons but like I I
basically like did suffer from bouts of
extreme binging again I didn't fall into
binge eating disorder criteria because I
also compulsively exercised to like undo
the binging so like I kept the balances
you know like you know waited correctly
but
um there was a point where I'd see my
friends at parties drink and they never
ate so I thought why don't I just drink
instead of eat like maybe that can
replace you know and ultimately I just
end up drinking and eating right which
is
yeah it's like okay I'm gonna add
another 10 miles tomorrow my run like so
it's like I'm very thankful that for
whatever reason despite our familiar
history like I didn't seem to have the
the gene that latched onto the alcohol
like because I was raised with that
awareness I like don't touch alcohol
like it's a really bad thing for our
family like you should not go close to
it and it's like the first time I took a
drink of alcohol I think was my
sophomore year sophomore year of college
and I was terrified like I asked my
friends like what's going to happen when
this touches my lips you know like and
and I was just a little sprue I was so
scared and um and I think but I don't
know like so they're they're definitely
is a component of just that that like
overall anxiety you know around a lot of
things
um but like with my
with my compulsions I mean
I
I have a hard time remembering some
things about like my childhood or my
life and that's probably pretty normal
um and I think what I've realized is
over the last you know 10 or 15 years
when I was really just like suffocating
in my own thoughts there wasn't room to
entertain the past you know of
experiences that were positive or
amazing like you know because I've had a
great life but I think I I just got so
focused on trying to get through the day
or that moment all I could think about
was numbers and food and my body and
these different you know compulsory
checks that I would perform
um but you know I I guess I I first
started to kind of notice this when I
was a kid
um like I I had kind of a
I guess I I had like a a challenging or
troubling experience at like a church
camp growing up and like
I must have been eight or nine yeah it
must been eight or nine and my mom you
know she we're I was raised very
religious
um and like we were sent away to a boys
Camp you know to learn how to let's just
say hunt fish tie knots all that fun
stuff and um and my mom was pretty
nervous because like I'm eight or nine
she's like oh he's too young and all of
her church lady friends were like no no
this is great like we'll send all the
kids you know all the boys are together
and so you know they sent me to Upstate
uh Minnesota that's where I grew up and
you know it I mean it was it was a great
experience you know we got to do all
that stuff but um it just so happened
that like our counselor he was this
recovering addict and I think he was six
months sober and he was a born-again
Christian he had found God and he wanted
to basically just share it with
everybody you know like he had to
profess what he had learned and he
wanted to share with everyone and
someone thought it was good for him to
be in charge of a nine-year-old you know
boys at a church camp and and so and one
thing with that experience was he was
big on the Book of Revelations and I
don't know have you ever read
Revelations
I can't remember the last time that I
did I know the story yeah you know I
think I know enough yeah you know it's
about end device yeah so it's what's
like a Stephen King novel to it at the
end of times yeah and and basically like
really instilled in us that like
unless you're unless you're a good
person you lead a perfect life and
unless you also like ask for you know
Jesus Come into your heart you will go
to hell and you'll burn forever and and
that was
a like I definitely you know had a hard
time with that and I think I so I end up
into this day like my mom will you know
bring her to tears on this but um like I
I wrote her a postcard from Camp that
said
and I didn't send it I tucked in my bag
and she found it a long time later but
uh it said something like like I don't
want to die here please come get me like
I'm having this thoughts again oh my God
and I I don't know where what that last
sentence was but like you know I may
have already been dealing with some sort
of intrusive thought but this this
basically like definitely kind of kicked
into high gear and and following that
experience like she she tells that like
the story that I then was really afraid
of everything like everything was gonna
kill me like I I wore clinging gloves
goggles and walked around with a Kleenex
like spray bottle just like disinfecting
everything because I was afraid that if
I got germs inside I would die and then
if I hadn't already asked him for
forgiveness for that one thing I just
did I'd end up in Hell Eternal in the
nation and so reflecting on all this
yeah well and I guess yeah it led to
compulsively praying and asking for
forgiveness basically with everything
like am I a good person did I do that
right am I perfect you know because it
you know I was learning that love was
conditional and that it was dependent on
basically you know something else
granting me that and and it and I'm not
here to say those are you know my
beliefs that shouldn't be taught or but
in my personal experience maybe it
wasn't the right time or the right place
or the right person to like really
instill these things and and that was my
first experience with a psychologist my
parents took me to a child psych and and
again I don't know why this is because
I'm sure they never said anything but
like I was terrified of going like
something in my head told me this is not
normal like you're broken and I
you know had a huge tantrum begged them
not to tell my siblings that I had gone
to a therapist like something in me at
that age knew that wasn't right you know
and and I don't know where that came
from but the the psychologists from what
my mom describes like said
you just have a really smart boy like he
he's really in tune to his surroundings
he's struggling with the home
environment my parents were going
through a separation like I you know you
know and I was I had a hard time with
that but it um he said you know it's
gonna
find its way through and and as far as I
know like I didn't really have any
lasting issues from like those
compulsory things and I didn't actively
try to get rid of it it just kind of
disappeared but that was my first
experience with kind of that stuff
um wow that's that's so interesting uh I
mean there's so much to unpack there I
mean basically you
survived a trauma and you found these
coping mechanisms that I don't know that
you outgrew they just became latent and
found their way you know to different
paths that you know kind of and they
served you like they allowed you to
survive in Excel as an athlete and all
these other areas I recently had
um
Sky Richard schwartzen who's got this
modality called internal family systems
which is super interesting it's it's the
idea the basic idea is we're not one
personality we're the composite of like
you know all different kinds of
personalities that are you know acting
up and vying for attention and when
something like OCD or a fear response
happens that's that one that's one piece
of your personality that was constructed
specifically to protect you in a certain
set of circumstances and it works it
does protect you but then you grow up
and you're not five years old or eight
or nine or ten and it's not serving you
anymore but it's still just as powerful
because it thinks that you're nine years
old and you're still at Camp right and
making peace with that and trying to
quell it and be like it's cool I'm good
now thank you I don't really need you
anymore but I appreciate all the hard
work that you've done for me yeah yeah
you know it's like this process of like
um understanding all of those different
triggers and aspects of your personality
to reconstruct you know a healthier one
for yourself and as you were sharing
that I was thinking about that and also
just the idea that I mean first of all
credit to your parents they like realize
that you needed some help and sought out
help which is great uh but you being so
young and pathologizing that and and
that just exacerbating your sense of
being being broken probably wasn't great
yeah and that's it like my parents are
amazing you know like I I I feel like I
had the best parents ever you know
provided a loving household always
reassured us that you know we were
welcomed accepted like and so it's weird
that like suddenly like some of these
things I deal with it's like oh well
obviously it probably came from like
just like your immediate Inner Circle
like you were you know whatever
something happened in that relationship
yeah like but it's not about vilifying
them or anything just because something
might have happened and maybe it wasn't
managed or dealt with you know in the
best way possible doesn't mean that
they're bad parents
people yeah it's they were doing the
best that they could under the
circumstances but it doesn't you know it
doesn't undercut the fact that certainly
you know something happened or a set of
things happened that you know set you on
a path uh you know kind of everything
that happened and where you are now and
I think probably this again is a
generational thing like each generation
tries to provide a better household and
experience for their kids right because
like my parents had like what I would
label as like traumatic childhoods
whereas like I had a bougie you know it
was it was chill yeah but you know there
you know there are just things that
happen and um and I think I think with
with um I don't know and maybe it's it's
a bit of a cultural thing but it's like
you know that that Minnesota nice you
know Lutheran Norwegian you show up on
Sunday with a hot dish and a smile and
everything's always good like you know
it's so like
I don't think I ever and no I know I
never
really started to talk about things that
happened and then at different stages in
life like you said okay maybe it kind of
disappeared and then it resurfaced in
experiences with bullying or then it
resurfaced in my competitive running you
know once I got to college and like
that's where suddenly the eating
disorder like surfaced up and like dealt
with other things so I think it it was
that the fact that I never truly
processed or
you know kind of even like teased out
what was happening it was just lurking
under the surface sure for something
else to trigger It Off
we're brought to you today by Roca
glasses are not something you normally
think about as a piece of performance
gear which when you think about it is
kind of insane because you can't perform
at your best if you can't see well the
Geniuses at Roka basically rebuilt
eyewear from the ground up no matter how
active you are or how much you sweat
these things never slip or fall off your
face they're super durable they look
awesome and they've got tons of super
classy modern styles to choose from I've
been rocking rokas for about four years
at this point I love them I'm a big fan
of the Hamilton style and gloss black
that's this Frame right here as well as
clear or I guess they call them vintage
on the website and if you want to try
them out for yourself you can do that
right now and unlock 20 off your order
with the code richroll
roca.com or you can click the link in
the description below okay back to the
show
you had mentioned earlier like you were
lucky that you know alcoholism runs in
your family but you sidestep that but
with alcoholism you stop drinking and
then you're on a path to sobriety like
you set it down and you don't have to
contend with it anymore whereas food you
have to eat every day so it haunts you
forever yeah you know it's like
streaming over you all the time which
yeah I actually think makes it more
difficult and then on top of that all of
these traits that over time
metastasize to become problematic enough
to address in the meantime help
construct
a personality
a lens on the world that fuel
exceptionalism success and results so
while you're in that build up you're
winning races you're getting better as a
runner you're a professional you're
doing all of these things
quietly these things are your
superpowers so your relationship to them
even if you know in your heart of hearts
like this is not good I shouldn't be
doing this but like look what's
happening yeah I'm on these podiums and
this so I I'm gonna keep doing this and
this is like working for me makes it
even more difficult when you have to
break up with them because they are your
best friends
there are times that I have been at my
sickest and Podium at UTMB and so it's
really hard to decouple those two right
and if you and if you do break up with
them then no more podiums yeah you're
you that's what your brain tells you
when in reality
it was a coincidence or it was you know
it was
um you know it wasn't causation that
because I held on to these certain
things that happened that then I
podiumed
arguably you probably could have done
better if you weren't dealing with all
these other things you know but I I do
agree with you I think that something
like
like obsessive-compulsive disorders
it is a bit of a superpower in the sense
that like it's really hard to manage
living in your own head when it's
basically you're dealing with intrusive
suffocating thoughts and you learn a lot
of resiliency
endurance patience which I mean you need
that in an ultra right like so there are
times where it's like
I almost feel thankful for I feel
thankful for those like the skills that
were developed I wish they had developed
in a different way you know and because
I I think the more I learn about even
Sports Psych
you can start to nurture those skill
sets
through much healthier Outlets you know
it doesn't have to be pathological but
it doesn't create the same kind of
hormonal brain Spike it's very
unfamiliar and feels not right right
like it's like
no I need to feel I need to feel like
I'm in pain or suffering or in this sort
of I have to conjure up a certain kind
of state that I can manufacture through
these behaviors to do it in the more
graceful way that requires a surrender
and a letting go and more of an allowing
feels like you know Walking on Mars
compared to a lifetime of a certain way
of doing things where you're getting the
result that you're seeking and you
definitely like anyone that's run before
the more you run the better you get you
know and there's that direct correlation
for a long time you know okay I'm going
to put in more I get more out obviously
there are tipping points and you know
roadblocks that happen but yeah you
start linking that and it becomes so
strong that you you can't imagine
performing without doing the things that
got you there yeah and I I think there
is that like yeah just being stubborn is
a really good asset until it isn't right
like right it it's a short-term strategy
it will get you to a certain point but
if you want to have longevity or reach
that you know kind of get off that
plateau and get to the next level you
know what got you there isn't the thing
that's going to get you to the next
place and there's a discomfort with that
and then on top of it being a runner and
with the food piece it's a weight weenie
sport like you know the lightweight
chassis is going to navigate those
mountains a little bit more gracefully
right so for any athlete who's in a
sport like that whether it's wrestling
running ultra running cycling Triathlon
where there's a power to weight thing or
even more aesthetic sports like
bodybuilding it's just they're they're
they're like
they're just Rife environments for kind
of cultivating these unhealthy
relationships with what we put in our
mouth totally and and I think
that is a we're starting to see
conversations change on that which I
love because when I was growing up in
high school and college it was the era
of either explicitly saying you should
look emaciated or it was implied you
know from some of the classic books and
other things that like I would you know
just you know ingest and you know what
people on the team would talk about and
you know your peers
um or rumors a lot of that you know or
you'd see people but it's um it I think
it's you have to acknowledge that weight
is a variable in running as you said
like okay like you can just do the
simple physics on this however it's a
low-hanging fruit that we latch onto
because we can manipulate weight pretty
quickly so we think if I'm this powerful
or stronger and like have that much
endurance and if I just weigh less I
will perform X better and and that just
isn't the truth because there are a lot
of other variables go into it and I
think it's easy for anyone to look at
and you know one of their running Idols
because I did this and you'd forget that
they may have been training their body
for 10 20 30 years to adapt into that
specific like body type
um it didn't just happen overnight and
there are genetic you know anomalies out
there where someone is just like they
don't have to manipulate their body and
they're going to have this particular
frame you know like I have very broad
shoulders Lindsay and I joke that I have
birthing hips like I will never be a
runner for a runner yeah I mean I'm
looking at you you're a pretty slight
dude yeah it's just that's like oh it
definitely you thinking like I'm too big
to be a runner and I'm looking at you
and I'm like you have the you have a
runner's physique yeah and which the
crazy thing is like at my worst when I
was battling with anorexia in college I
was almost 35 pounds less than I am
right now which I don't wow like
I can acknowledge my brain still says
you have 35 pounds you could lose but I
know that's not true like I can just
like start to acknowledge that and move
on but like in college like I don't have
35 pounds to lose like and it became a
point where coach my coach my teammates
they were worried and bring it up and
then you go into that defensive angry
method of like I got everything fine
like why are you accusing me and you
know it's just that immediate you know
kind of right you know self-preservation
when you were 35 pounds lighter in
addition to just the training and the
mileage yeah uh like what was a day in
food
for you then like what did it look like
it was
I was restricting an incredible amount
while training very heavily for a
distance Runner
um because I I just had this
very arbitrary and and reduced thought
that I should always be consuming less
than 2 000 calories a day even if I'm
running 90 to 100 miles a week and so
over time you build up a huge deficit
where your body starts to cannibalize
itself you know because you need
nutrients to
fuel normal brain function hormones your
your bone density all these things
um and but you're like great cannibalize
away because I'm trying to get smaller
yep I mean and I hate to say this but
probably the highest high I've ever had
is that euphoric feeling of like
feeling
like my bones or clothes hanging off of
me or seen the number on the scale like
that
was like it's it's the needle in the arm
it's better than standing on the top of
utmb's Podium like and which is a weird
really strange thing to say but I also
know at the same moment
I was so unhappy
lonely
isolated like terrified so it I'd like I
would never want to go back to that but
it was something that was powerful and
what was your level of self-awareness
around
um you know the disease or or disorder
aspect of what you were doing because I
just know from my own experience it's
like you cut you know this isn't right
or good you just kind of push that down
and you're like it's fine I got this I'm
under control
it'll be cool I definitely knew it I
mean I think when you engage in certain
behaviors where
like you immediately have shame around
what you just did like and you wouldn't
be able to tell a friend what you just
engaged with I think you you know that
you're doing something that's not right
like if you couldn't tell your
grandmother that you were just like
eating out of the trash or like whatever
you just did like you know you know some
sort of you know purging Behavior like
that's not that's not okay right um and
and I think that's where like
the probably the components that I built
as an adolescent of like really being
hyper cognizant of my appearance and of
my the way I carry myself everything
from my voice to my hair to my you know
to you know my posture all these things
like I was just hyper cognizant of being
judged I think that led into okay now
I'm an athlete and I see all these other
athletes and and it's a very reduced
view you see athlete X perform and you
think it's because they look a certain
way and again you don't know what the
training was that went into that you
don't know their individual biological
differences and and what I noticed was I
was very fortunate like I was never the
best or even close to the best runner in
high school college even Pros like as a
marathoner but I had opportunities
because I had friends with really fast
people to like get into these training
groups like in Mammoth and like run and
do easy runs for Meb like and and do
long runs with them but like my brain's
comparing me with Meb like that's not a
fair comparison like that that's just
not like that should have never happened
right I mean just kind of drop into
Mammoth like if if comparison is the
thief of Joy like you're in an
environment where you know that
comparison that you're running in your
mind is gonna drive you insane oh yeah
because I was broken
and was that uh was Ryan Hall still
married you know doing his marathon
thing at that time like because he
obviously he was like I mean he got so
lean or whatever to the point and then
whether he over trained or you know
whatever was going on at that point I
mean now he's a completely different
human being but you know at that at that
time it looks like he kind of took that
all the way to the wall he he definitely
I I think he would say he got everything
he could out of himself
um he had transitioned out a mammoth
right when I got there like Lindsay and
I moved there in 2011 for an internship
um at the hospital as a her for my
therapist and
um at that point Terence the coach he
was still in charge of the mammoth Track
Club Ryan and Sarah had just left but
like Sarah came back and I did some
training with her but like it was Meb
Dina uh Morgan yuseny and Anna Willard
or Anna Pierce and you know so it was It
was kind of track heavily focused
um with a few really stud marathons just
like green and Meb right yeah
um I've had conversations on this
podcast with
Amelia Boone about her you know
analogous
um adventures in you know in in this
world of like struggling with
relationship to food I had Mary Kane in
here and certainly there's no shortage
of of running institutions especially
when women and girls are involved where
the powers that be are are kind of
issuing an Edict of uh not so healthy
you know uh Dynamics around food that
have led to you know a lot of problems
and there's been a lot of spotlights uh
you know shown on that world but what
does that look like when you're a male
athlete do you have coaches that are
saying you need to drop weight or what
is the you know kind of the power
Dynamic when you're underneath somebody
who's guiding your career and and and
the kind of ripple effect on your
relationship with food
I was very fortunate that my coaches
never had those conversations in terms
of like we need to manipulate things
it doesn't seem to be a thing with guys
no and I I mean to to my coaches Credit
in college like Gary he pulled me aside
and said I'm worried about you like are
you eating enough like and so he noticed
something was happening you know I think
in the back that was
2006 you know it was quite a while ago
now I I think at that time it was much
more taboo you know he had the talk you
know he recognized it but I I don't know
if he knew what to do with it you know
where I think now we have much better
systems in place where it's like okay
like let's get you in touch with our
school nutritionist or the school psych
or let's talk to the you know the Gen
the GP and I think those types of things
have improved a lot where because as a
coach you're kind of like the gatekeeper
like you're not the expert of everything
yeah but you are dealing with the
athlete the most so you should be able
to acknowledge and then pass you off an
athlete off to someone that needs that
expertise and as you said like in the
worst case scenarios like with a Mary
Kane or NOP you had bad actors playing
roles they shouldn't have been playing
under the guise of I'm guiding this
career and that's tragic like that's
really a horrible situation and I think
the more things are talked about we can
start to undo some of that negative you
know you know those negative Pathways
and then also
the stigmatic or the like destigmatizing
that like okay like it it's not a male
thing because
I'm sure there are plenty of men in all
those Sports he listed that have had
some sort of experience or at least
thoughts on this stuff and then worst
case and and that goes back to what you
said the very beginning you know and I
was talking to another Pro uh marathoner
about this like you know there are
people in sports that like engage in
disordered behavior for a season you
know because they're like hey my
nutritionists or someone in my medical
team says I do need to cut weight for
this boxing match like and so that stuff
happens and it
could technically be done like with
proper guidance but the addict or the
just like the person that actually
suffering they can't turn it off when
it's over like and so it will just
continue it'll keep going despite the
season being over and it doesn't end
until you know something intervenes or
like you know you hit your proverbial
Rock Bottom yeah yeah and I think that
lives on a spectrum it's not a light
switch right you know like right now
um
I've got a lower back Condition it's
really got me benched and I can't move
the way that I would like and I haven't
been able to run I've just been way more
sedentary than I have in a long time and
so
put on a little weight a little flabby
you know looking in the mirror not not
that's not really how I want to look and
you know I can feel myself like you know
how does that impact how I first of all
then I don't feel good as good in the
world and I don't feel like myself and
my brain doesn't work and that alters my
relationship with food in a way and I'll
avoid you know like some of that's fine
and perfectly healthy and some of it I
can feel myself being a little
compulsive about like I'm not I wouldn't
consider myself to have a a an eating
disorder but I noticed that you know
compulsive kind of obsessive
um tickle on the back of the brain you
know and uh and it was weird we were
tired I was at the Strava event
yesterday there's always super fit
people you know it's just like and like
everyone's looking at me oh you're the
guy with the pocket you know it's like
and I'm like yeah but I'm kind of like
yeah and I go through all of that like
insecurity and you know I want to acquit
myself and be the guy like people are
projecting onto me because they think
they have a relationship with me because
they've listened to the podcast whatever
and all of that is spinning in my head
and it and it's like it's really hard to
just get quiet and realize like you know
it gives a [__] like yeah you're cool
like everyone's happy you're here it's
fine and I think you don't have to go on
the group run in the morning and like
you know be in the lead pack and all of
that like but that's that's what's
looping and I've heard you say like
you're not worried about racing against
the best at UTMB and how long you're
going to be out there and the suffering
and how hard it's going to be you're
freaked out about the fun run two days
ahead of time
yeah which is it's a really strange
thing to
like it's almost like a both and I know
I'm a competent and accomplished Runner
but at the same time I don't think I'm
Val like I'm worthy of being called a
runner or showing up in the world with
people because I didn't feel thin enough
or I didn't like it was terrifying so
someone says to you congrats or like wow
you know what you've done is amazing
like do you kind of contract and feel
Unworthy of receiving nice things being
said about you
yes and maybe a good example is in 2017
arguably probably the best race in my
career and that's when you got third at
UTMB yeah and shared the podium with
friends 20 hours yep yeah with Francois
and Killian like
the moment like approaching the Finish
Line like it was pure joy like I just
done something I dreamed of like I had
like silenced the haters and the the
voices in my head I just like was
triumphant but the half-life of that
happiness
didn't even make it to the podium the
next day like that next morning I hopped
on a bike and I was like trying to spin
out my legs I showed up and thankfully
like we had Podium jackets that I could
wear but jackets or shelves that I would
always cover my body in so I wore pants
and jackets on a hot day saying on the
podium like super uncomfortable but like
afraid of what people might think of me
12 hours ago I just run one of the best
races like ever at UTMB but it didn't
last like and it seemed like the more I
got into my career especially the last
couple years like
that happiness Half-Life got shorter and
shorter and shorter and shorter like or
it needed more and more to like trigger
something as being Worthy
yeah the insanity of that right yeah
like and I say it and it's like I know
and even more like for people who are
trying to wrap their heads around like
how like just to inhabit the mind the
insane mind of this you've talked about
um one of the reasons why you like UTMB
and were you would dismiss Western
States ah it's not Technical and blah
blah blah but the real reason you liked
UTMB is that you start in the dark and
you got a good 12 hours of of you know
hiding in darkness uh to sweat enough to
drop a little bit of weight so that by
the time people actually see you you
feel like you look the way you would
like to look yeah when that is like that
encapsulates like everything you need to
know about the insanity of of yeah of
this disorder and because I literally
see myself as overweight
like even though
the you know we might have objective
augmented feedback that says otherwise
like I would see myself differently so
like but once I cross that threshold of
exercising enough something flips in my
brain and I start to feel that okay the
scales are balancing appropriately and
it yeah it's just pretty unfortunate
that you have to go to those lengths to
achieve that and then it doesn't last
like yeah and then that with the
half-life shrinking or your inability to
like be present and experience Joy at
your own accomplishments is a situation
in which you can make peace with that
because your job isn't to be joyful and
happy your job is to perform right and
if this set of behaviors gets you on a
Podium even if it doesn't produce Joy
that's a deal you're willing to make
because you need to excel because love
is conditional and you can't get that
love unless you do these things out in
the world and whether you're able to
experience that or not for yourself is
almost beside the point or irrelevant I
think that's well encompassed yeah you
know yeah
so so where does it I mean obviously
there's a percolating awareness like
that you're doing things that you're not
proud of or not willing to kind of share
with other people uh and and I would
suspect it it's building there's a
pressure cooker aspect to it but where
does it start to really flare up in a
way where you realize like at some point
maybe soon I'm going to need to address
this as you're kind of careening off the
edge or nearing your bottom
I probably really started to notice some
some like cracks like in the that
exterior shell that I like because I I
held everything together really well and
uh and I I think there was almost like a
pride aspect of that that's part of it
too is control definitely like and
and that's all the Resurgence seeking
behaviors of like a compulsive disorder
is trying to establish insert control
like how do I know I didn't eat too much
I'm going to count like how do I know
that wasn't too much I'm gonna weigh
that how you know whatever it like in
and so I started to see it really I I
think part of it was Lindsay went back
to school in about
it must have been right around that like
UTMB 2017 or so like so we lived apart
for about 18 months and she was away at
school and I think you know I started to
realize how much I relied on her for you
know some grounding and some stability
and and for a long time in our
relationship I I really
I felt like I was the rock you know like
you know I helped her get through things
and you probably had the expense of my
ability to share anything you know so
when I started to talk to her about
things it was a bit of a shock like you
know she always knew there were some
things going on but not the extent of
what was happening because I could
internalize it that well and um but I
think
starting to see how much it was
impacting our relationship was a bit of
that like big crack in the you know in
the vase where it's like seeing that my
actions and you know the things that I'm
I thought I had been under control are
hurting other people I think that was a
big turning point and then when she left
for school
it was also like I think that was
probably the first time in my life that
I maybe like you know kind of dabbled
into the depressive state where again I
I'm a pretty happy person like even
though I dealt with all this stuff it
felt like I still liked life but like
when she was gone I think I started to
feel more isolated and lonely
um and and I think probably a
combination of seeing how much some
things I was doing was impacting her and
hurting and then like scaring myself
that I was having a hard time seeing you
know a future like if you wake up or I
would wake up at 5am 6 a.m and just be
terrified of getting out of bed because
the thoughts would already have just
crashed on me and I knew the moment I
went downstairs I was going to kind of
like numb those thoughts with food and
then by 6 a.m I would have consumed all
the calories I need for a day
and then I know I have to somehow
survive the next 14 hours in the world
knowing I can't eat because I've eaten
too much it was just like a life of
Terror yeah like and and it's exhausting
it's exhausting and as what you said
earlier I think is is fascinating where
you know if you think about communities
historically from beginning of time like
we come together around food food's an
amazing thing and
you can't live without it you have to
have it that sustenance feeds us fuels
us allows us to grow but
there are times where food felt like it
was this enemy and I couldn't be trusted
around it you know you go into a grocery
store and it's like I don't know the
like the pharmacist just gave you the
keys and he left and he's like go have
at it yeah and like and again this also
comes from a place of privilege where
like I have the ability to purchase what
I want so like I'm not in a Stark State
I'm not in a true deprived State like
for some reason my brain's making me do
these things but that that's kind of
just what I was living in so I think it
was day-to-day struggling to get through
where you just want tomorrow to come
like you can't wait for tomorrow and
when you're living in that like
state of you just want the next day
you're not living you're you're not ever
present you're missing out on life and I
think there was a degree of that was
like hey
you maybe not ha you don't have it as
put together as you thought you did and
this isn't a way to live and that's
where
I mean in that that chorus film I'm
really thankful koros chose to to
support that that film you know I had
approached some other sponsors and they
weren't as interested but chorus thought
it was a powerful thing to to talk about
and so I'm very thankful to Chorus for
that um essentially it was like you're
not okay anymore you know like something
needs to give and it's not a fault to
ask for help I think I was still lashed
on to that like I can just tough through
this like I can I can do anything like
you know it's uh right because self-will
is in Your Arsenal of superpowers
because you don't achieve Excellence as
a marathon or or an athlete in any field
if you're not somebody who has the
capacity to deploy your self-will to
procure a certain result yeah so why
shouldn't that thing that is so that I'm
so good at why can't that should be able
to solve this problem I'll just I'll
just redirect it here and we'll take
care of it yeah and you have to go
through the Journey of you know trying
that until you realize that uh yeah it's
just making the whole thing worse and
and meanwhile that I want to talk a
little bit more about
um that Journey from denial to
acceptance and understanding that your
behavior because the thing is you covet
this behavior and you're like it's not
harming anyone else I'm just gonna do
this like [__] off you know but then
realizing it is impacting others
negatively like
what do you mean by that when your wife
started when you started to realize that
it was it was having a negative impact
on her
the first time I really noticed it was
actually um
when I was in grad school so this would
have been like 2009 2010 like
Lindsay is a saint she she was she's
always been very financially
um like insecure like she's worried
about finances you know like that's
that's kind of like it it scares her and
I think that you know so as I was going
through grad school her goal was she
wanted me to finish without student
loans so she did not want me to take out
a loan and she worked two jobs to
support us throughout school and we only
had one car so she was run commuting to
work while training as a marathoner so I
could take the car to the university and
I didn't understand this tool years
later but like I was dealing with some
of that anxiety I had in other areas of
my life in school and all these things
still through food and we would get into
fights over me spending money
at school on food because she had us on
a very tight budget you know it was a
budget that was you know it was
realistic we could do it and the
ultimate goal is we wanted to get out
without loans
um but and so she was very adamant on
that and like you know she's working
hard in all these other areas
I was struggling and starting to
suffocate dealing with these emotions I
didn't really understand why so I would
end up buying these things to make it
temporarily like you know quell that
anxiety
that would lead to arguments or fights
and you know something I didn't want to
do so that led to me starting to lie and
hide those things which is not a good
thing in a relationship yeah so the
intimacy gets eroded and Trust I I
ultimately I I end up taking out a
student loan
privately
that I didn't tell her about yeah you
did so that I could yeah like these
purchases a good part yeah this is the
[__] I always hear about so like so I
could go out and like you know have a
binge or whatever it was and she didn't
know about it because like I hated
making her angry I that was the last
thing I ever wanted to do but I I also
didn't know how to not do these things
right like there was some link where I
was experiencing so much Suffocation the
only thing I knew how to get through
that was to engage it has to eat and
you're gonna find a way yep you're gonna
have to be crafty and then I would have
so much like guilt around what I just
did and or shame of lying to her
and so that the only solution to that
being either starving yourself or eating
right like so it's just the Vicious
Cycle perpetuates and you dig the hole
deeper and deeper until you're alone in
a dark room yeah yeah so she needless to
say she wasn't real happy when she found
out about your private loan but then it
was kind of like earlier it's like oh I
go on and like thing like I somehow
piece it back together and things are
okay and never really addressed it again
I think it was a pride thing and it was
an embarrassment thing acknowledging
that I was struggling like and I didn't
want to ask for help because I thought I
could deal with it myself I I guess the
next real big one was one of my
compulsions with all the um food related
stuff was you know the counting you know
so I have this obsessive thought that
invades my head causes an incredible
amount of anxiety so I then count to
reassure myself that what I was afraid
of isn't happening and for years that
compulsion was more of a physical I had
to like add it up on my phone's
calculator so I had actually like like
just physically do that and that
actually started back in like 2004
um back when I was on a cross-country
trip with my coach and I don't know if
you remember these days but like you had
to pay per text message back then like
and like my coach like man you're you're
just blowing up like I was like no like
yeah you know it kind of popular but uh
I was so mad at people when they texted
me because like I didn't have the money
to pay for each text so like I was
actually just adding up on my phone's
calculator I wasn't texting people but
like I played it off as I was just on my
phone all the time I was just texting
um but there were times over
I mean it's happened numerous but where
you know I've almost wrecked my car
because I'm adding up on the calculator
because I can't not know where I am in
the count
and the worser if Lindsay's sleeping in
the passenger seat
like you know we're coming down Highway
50 a windy road through the mountains of
Tahoe
you know she wakes up it's like all
right because you're like doing this
weird OCD thing on your calculator
I could not no I understand it's a it's
that's the powerlessness part of it
right yeah and it makes you feel
horrible like the unmanageability like
so you think you're just doing this
thing and nobody should bother you about
it and uh it takes a while before you
realize that the chaos that you're
creating all around you yeah and then it
doesn't matter whether it's drugs or
alcohol or gambling or relationships or
whatever shopping yeah yeah like you say
replace X and there are similar themes
probably through a lot of this yeah like
and then I I found actually through
therapy starting to open up and talk
about things also was hard because that
made me realize how the things I would
say about myself were hurting other
people because obviously if I'm saying
these things about me I'm judging others
indirectly through those types of
comments you know like you said like I
am a athletic built dude like if I think
I have weight to lose what does that say
about you like so like there's that like
reflective piece that was really also
hard because I always thought it was
just you know I'm dealing with myself
and what I'm struggling with but it's
actually hurting the Judgment that you
have towards everybody else which it's a
fascinating nobody's judging but
nobody's judging you that way certainly
not the way you're judging yourself and
it and I didn't find myself judging
other people the way I judged myself of
course not and and I think that's where
that's the secret like no one actually
cares we all think everyone's looking at
us no one is like no one's actually
paying attention to you just reflect for
a moment on your own level of
self-obsession yeah and and just realize
like even even if they took year 10 and
you tune it down to five people are just
still walking around thinking about
themselves so like relax dude yeah and I
think that's where that's an important
like turning point in anyone when you're
struggling with something is that
acknowledging that and I I poke fun at
Lindsay all the time on this and it uh
she'll she'll just you know kind of
harass me and say you're not special and
it's like it's true I'm not special like
we we all have something going on like
we internalize the other attic thing the
the sense of terminal uniqueness you
have no idea how this is different how
different I am and how complicated and
special my problems are and you'll never
understand and I can't ever talk about
it with anybody because they wouldn't
understand and it's not until uh you
know you're in that recovery process and
you realize like you know the person
you're working with or the community
that you're sharing with like it's all
they're all like yeah of course duh like
exactly you know the facts of the you
know your story are going to be
different from the other person but the
thoughts and the emotions and the
feelings are exactly the same and this
is something I does change is just
resources for
Eating Disorders or OCD improve and are
more readily available because in some
of those periods that I was describing
when Lindsay was away at school I
considered attending AA because I
couldn't find a support group like I
couldn't find anyone to talk to and but
in a small community like mammoth
I was terrified that I would know every
single person in that meeting and some
of them would be my patients and it
actually the meeting was held in our
clinic in the conference room and like
so it was like too incestual that I I
didn't and then there was that sense of
like well I don't deal with alcohol like
I can't show up there that's that's not
respectful to other people and but there
you know I was seeking someone to like
hopefully like you know give me tools to
work with you know and and then
eventually it led to actually getting
therapy one-on-one but in this country
that's very cost prohibitive for a lot
of people like yeah it's challenging
yeah
um yeah I mean if I was Secretary of
that a meeting I would have let you in
thank you I would have given you
permission to yeah but yeah so it's it
it is a weird thing and that's why it's
Anonymous right there's the stigma and
the the fear and the the self-judgment
and the fear of others judging you and
and how does that reflect I mean when
it's in your clinic where you work like
it's close to home it's scary so was
there was it just a Dawning realization
like okay I got I have to deal with this
how am I going to deal with it or did
was there like a bottom where something
bad happened and you're like okay like
Lindsay's like pack your bags dude or or
get help or you know how did it kind of
go down
thankfully that never happened but I
think it was more that realization that
I don't see a future
living this way in my head you know just
getting through
moments in a day or an entire day was so
exhausting it was hard to imagine
actually being a partner to her
like definitely we would never have kids
like we would never have a dog like I
couldn't handle any of that stuff and I
think that started to scare me that I
just didn't
I didn't want to be around basically
like so there there wasn't like a
particular moment or an action but I I
saw where it was heading and and around
those same you know in 2017 when she was
away
um we had a close friend he he had lost
his life to suicide and then I'd lost a
few friends to the mountains and I think
there was this compounding thing of like
the fragility of life where I had a
pretty privileged life and I didn't lose
anyone other than some grandparents that
I started to really kind of like
sit with how
yeah like how fragile this existence is
and and I think that really started to
scare me that I didn't trust myself in
terms of like knowing I can't live this
way and so that was the impetus to
finally you know seek out and start
treatment and and Lindsay was very
encouraging of that
um it I did cancel multiple my first
visits because
a combination of that still shame like
being embarrassed that I would have to
talk to someone about it and then also
in the small community my therapist was
downstairs from my clinic
and in the waiting room were my patients
you're gonna see the guy in the bathroom
like so like I'd go in and like the the
mental health services were with
Orthopedics so I would be in the waiting
room in patient x what are you doing
here Tim I'm like oh you know I'm just
I'm checking up on you you know I I'd
spend some story and so there was a lot
of that just like embarrassment and and
shame where I it probably took me almost
two years before I actually told people
in the waiting room oh I'm here for
myself like I I no longer had that that
story
it's so interesting that the the help
that you found was literally downstairs
from where you worked the whole time
yeah uh and you could have I mean you
could have gone to inpatient somewhere
you could have gone to a you know a
treatment center or something like that
um but you found it in your own building
all along and that's been your recovery
modality it makes sense it's been the
main one I mean there are times where I
wanted or still want to go to like an
inpatient facility but the the I think
there's part of my brain it's like no no
you don't need that or like oh that's
too expensive and like worried about all
these other you know collateral things
um but what I what I realized is like so
it's been over three years now I think
the first and and so actually this is I
think important like I I was very
resistant to trying medication like it
was another one of those like well
that's not me like I had some internal
stigma around it even though I never
passed that on to my patients like when
I learned they were taking meds like
because it's therapeutic you know there
are reasons why you might take a med
um but three months ago I started
fluoxetine which is an SSRI and I was
resistant for probably two years and the
the nice thing is my therapist never
pushed it just said hey these are tools
that are available but let's try these
things and you know just if we might
need to and when it was maybe kind of
suggested I was very hands off on it but
I think that for me personally really
stalled a lot of my progress because in
the last three months since starting
this I've actually been able to start to
think a little clearer because like this
like
cloud of we'll call it cloud of counting
was so dense
I would go through a therapy session
like every week and I'd leave feeling
like I just got out of church camp you
know like you know I'm filled with the
spirit I'm gonna go preach to everyone
and then like five minutes later I had
forgotten it and reality struck me in
the face and I just was in this kind of
cycle back to the loop back into it and
and I eventually kind of connected with
okay maybe that component of like the
compulsive Behavior or the you know the
behaviors is preventing for me from
actually getting into these other things
so I would say I am I'm very grateful
for where I'm at now but I know there's
still a lot to be done because I
immediately just fall back into you know
the old patterns like I raced I was at a
um actually yeah I was in
Spain 10 days ago for a race and like I
almost derailed my entire like build up
because of a trigger that shouldn't
trigger me anymore you know like and so
it highlighted that hey you're still
in this vulnerable state where you have
your quiver is getting more robust and
like I'm very proud of that but I I need
to refine that and continue to work on
it and it seems it has to be like a
daily practice Yeah I mean you're three
years in yeah uh you know on some level
that's early recovery right and you
speak about it very eloquently and you
have a grasp on the condition and how
it's impacted you and the way forward
but the brain and its rewiring takes a
little bit longer and those triggers
don't go away the recovery is about
noticing them as they arise and and
having that extra moment to not act on
them and to take a contrary action and
to the extent that the SSRI can can
function as a pattern interrupt or be
you know another tool in that quiver
there's nothing wrong with that but it's
probably good that you didn't do it
right away like you're you're because
then you can sort of just divest
response well I'm taking this drug I've
dealt with it or whatever but the
shoulder the responsibility for for your
own recovery and realize that you know
you're you know three years in and it's
still this is still you know it's like
you're not over it like this is
something you live with and you develop
these tools and those tools become rote
and routine but they need to be
practiced and uh and uh you know because
in the in in that dark you know lonely
room that uh that disorder is doing its
push-ups so to speak and just waiting
for a vulnerable moment uh to LEAP yeah
and I think that that parallel with
sport is really impactful where
I didn't get here overnight and I cannot
run it as quickly just like we didn't
get to these levels of achievement
overnight it took year after year after
season after season of building and it
became a habit and so you know I think
recovery is a habit you have to
continually practice it and like you
said Flex that muscle and get it
stronger and be kind with yourself when
you mess up and that's something I am
not good about and I don't think a lot
of people are as that self-compassion
like the things we say to ourselves are
horrible and you would never say that
out loud like I I don't even tell my
therapist the things I say to myself you
know like but it's like how do we
like you can't live that way you have to
be compassionate towards yourself
that's a tough one like what are the
tools that you practice to get over that
piece because I struggle with that just
acknowledging that something is and
trying not to place judgment on it good
or bad like okay I over ate today
that happened like that doesn't
inherently mean it was bad like but I
have to accept it I don't have to like
what happened but I can acknowledge that
I'm human that that did occur and what
am I going to do next you know and not
get hung up on you know that because
Revelations yeah exactly careful there
but uh
um because you know no amount of guilt
will ever change the past
and no amount of anxiety can shape the
future you really need to kind of bring
it back into that present moment
and and that's where I'm kind of
starting to realize like I'm relearning
all these things like I still don't
trust myself with food like I'm
relearning my relationship with it but
in that I'm also relearning like what it
is to have fun you know like it's like
it's almost been like a kid again in
terms of like all these new experiences
of like oh like
having a meal where you're not thinking
about every micronutrient or
macronutrient that's in your food and
Counting and being worried about all
these things off in the future or what
you just ate like and actually listening
to someone talk is a pretty cool thing
you know like being truly immersed in a
conversation and present like I mean I I
think you you facilitate like this
really nice space because
I don't know how long we've been going
but I haven't counted once like that's
not that's good like I I was counting
this morning I was worried about coming
in and seeing you because like I haven't
been running much it's been a week off
from my race you know so all these
things I and I think that's part of the
compassion thing is like thoughts are
automatic you right and that's control
that right that's huge progress if you
can sit and have a meal and not be doing
the thing that you've done for decades
obsessively and compulsively and get to
the other end of the meal and realize
you didn't do it that's like massive
progress so I'm interested in the
experience of going into a grocery store
or entering a restaurant like what like
what was going on in your mind
previously in terms of the foods that
would find their way into you like what
you're thinking about when you're
pushing the cart down the aisles then
versus like what it's like now and how
because you You Gotta Eat Right and
you're still trying to you know perform
as an athlete like all of all of those
are triggers that you can't avoid in
your life no you have to confront them
and find new strategies so that's that's
really tricky
the the short answer is I fell into the
cost convenience and
um comfort choices like what could give
me the fix the quickest and that's
normally something high sugar high fat
that I can just devour that takes no
prep so as processed foods and uh and
again like this is one of those like I
curated this notion that like I'm the
donut guy like I love donuts and I do
but like
like how Scott fawl is the burrito the
burrito guy like donuts donuts and dirt
were my thing you know like and and that
that is something that I still like you
know but a donut is great a dozen donuts
is excessive like probably for anyone
um and uh so I think with with the food
stuff
I didn't know how to control and there
were times where like the like the like
binges have a very clear diagnostic kind
of Criterium but like the you know the
uncontrolled you know kind of
consumption would occur a lot
um and and it kind of just felt
powerless so one of the you know
strategies was just elimination try and
like keep things out of sight or out of
our house
um and the unfortunate thing like you
said like as an athlete you have to
train so you have to fuel and and this
is where I'm thankful that you know my
about with anorexia was in college and
over the last decade plus it's been more
this like like I said the um the ausfed
the other specified feeding eating
disorder where it's kind of like a
mashup of a lot of different components
because if I was still actually
restricting to the point of weight loss
I would be perpetually injured and as a
distance Runner you have no career if
you're continually injured and that's
where you know other people they've
suffered or they suffered long enough in
that critical time period of their
adolescence or early 20s their bone
density could permanently be damaged
like in like I feel grateful that I
didn't have that occur because I've
never thought of myself as talented but
actually my biggest superpower is my
durability so like you know I've hated
myself for never being thin enough or
skinny with the durability but the
durability has allowed me in having a
little more you know meat on your bones
and yeah and I'm doing this 20 years
later without injury because of that
durability like and so that was never a
deficit but I think you know
acknowledging you know our our
inadequacies aren't
things that make us less of a per like
you know less worthy of acceptance or
love but you know you should celebrate
that
um but I ended up using running as
really a mask to hide behind where
I if I lost my control around food or a
meal or events
I knew I had this secret weapon I could
just go out and run four or five six
hours without eating or drinking right
and like and I also would chalk it up so
I'm working on fat adaptation like you
know I heard Killian talking I'm getting
better though like all day and like so
this is what we're supposed to be doing
yeah so but then when you do that every
day or every big training block that's
not how it's done like you have to be
selective and you have to be thoughtful
and really precise and recognize that
the recovery is important where if I
went out and ran for five hours without
food or water I wouldn't come home and
then eat everything I was in that
euphoric State yeah and I would not
recover the way I should have and and I
don't think any of this stuff like I I'm
not of the belief that had I figured
this out I would have been a better
performer I just think I would have been
happier throughout my entire career like
and I do well I do think there would
have been more consistent performances
like I could have avoided a lot of the
huge pitfalls failures or blow-ups I had
because a lot of those were mental or
physical because I wasn't treating my
body well you know I wasn't nourishing
it
um and and that that is hard because I
mean it to perform you know and and it
has real life consequences of like you
can lose your job right if you don't
perform yeah like yeah I mean yeah
exactly so there are there are you know
amazing pressures on top of all of this
outside of just you know how you're
interacting with your peers at work and
your partner at home
um we're like an hour and a half into
this we haven't even talked about
running it's like we should probably
point out that like I told you how to
get it running yeah like I can run my
mouth yeah like
um you have this uh you're kind of like
average in high school you go to college
uh you start having some success you
take your shot at marathoning I think
you're like a 218 PR marathoner two
two-time Olympic trials qualifier but uh
recognize you're not gonna kind of get
to that next you know super Elite level
you find the trail world you have
success I think your first Ultra you won
the 50k US championships that's true so
like right out of the gate distinguished
Nike contract and then
um UTMB in 2017 was was that that was
your top race right when you got third
yeah I got third in 2016 as well right
but you were two that was 22 hours yeah
and then yeah the following year under
20. so the world is looking very bright
uh everybody's looking at you the next
big thing and you win a lot of races
after that tons of races but
you couldn't quite recapture some of
those you know High highs or whatever
you've had you know some some
disappointing results over the years uh
and I'm sure a lot of that is wed to
everything that we've been talking about
today so I'm interested not so much in
going back and rehashing old stuff but
how you're thinking about your training
and your racing now I heard you say at
some point that a big part of your
motivation
uh came from a place of anger and
certainly in recovery that's got to be
replaced with something better and more
sustainable so
um what does that look like for you now
like it's got to be a totally different
relationship with the thing that you do
professionally
it is
and to what we spoke about earlier like
thinking that maybe these
these things I battled were actually a
superpower there's been that fear of
letting it go and then when you pair it
with subpar performances you start to
connect those dots and think oh yeah
it's because you're not doing these
things anymore like and it would be so
easy to go back and just do that yeah
and like I have to fight that thought
but I always remind myself of how lonely
and isolating and unhappy I was in those
moments even when outwardly I was having
success like I was pretty empty and
there was never going to be enough so
like if I had one U team being one of
those years I honestly think it would
have been worse because I would have
doubled down on everything because that
was pre-starting therapy I think my my
life would have really struggled as a
result if if everything I basically am
afraid of
then was Amplified to an 11. because of
that you know success or notoriety I I
would have completely crumbled
um but I think some of what I'm really
working on is
making sure I acknowledge that okay
I am very proud of the steps I'm taking
in terms of recovery
and separating that from my performances
so just because you know the last couple
years I've had some pretty tough breaks
on the biggest stage at Western States
and at UTMB and it would be easy to say
okay you're you're past your Prime you
know you're washed up or you just don't
have it anymore but or
linking it okay it's because I'm not
doing these things but I I'm confident
that I just have had a string of bad
luck you know and that's the sport ultra
running is hard like unless you're
Courtney or Jim right like you like and
I always wanted to be that but I have to
acknowledge I'm human like I'm of this
earth and the reality is I'm gonna lose
99 of the events I line up for but I'm
like I still hold on to that one big
dream that I'll eventually get it and
that's what keeps me showing up and
starting to see that like
my individual success
doesn't have to be the top of the podium
like there's so many ways for me to
achieve like my best results even
letting go of what other people do which
is hard yeah one of the things that I
got out of the the koros stock which
also chronicled you running Western
States
um was the fact that even though you had
a disappointing result you were kind of
fast out of the gate things didn't go
quite as you planned that there was a
joy and uh and and a sense of connection
and uh and like community that was
really buoyant for you and very
different from reaching the heights of
of being on the podium at UTMB and going
under 20 hours like even though the
result wasn't what you wanted the lived
experience of that was somehow more
meaningful and important
for sure and that was I think the
community part was huge because in the
past I've always prided myself on this
Lone Wolf mentality and it which is
laughable because no one does anything
alone you know we always have help from
the moment we're born to any achievement
but there's something in that you know
is this like you know self-made
athlete or ex or entrepreneur or
whatever it is and like that I can do it
alone and asking for help is a weakness
or asking for help shows that I you know
like vulnerability is something I
shouldn't you know lean into and so I
think with that first experience with
States and even last year
yeah last year I you know welcoming my
inner crew and actually letting them in
to help me
it was so much more powerful and
meaningful because I do feel like we
created something more beautiful as a
result for having been broken and then
coming out the other side than if I just
knocked it out of the park you know and
and what was fascinating is the amount
of people that reached out afterwards
and like shared their stories or wanted
to connect
because I hadn't given up on myself and
I finished it was far more reaching than
if I had won the race you know and and I
think that was a like another important
reminder that people aren't going to
remember the races you won or the
records you set or you know the the IPOs
you hit and like all these things it's
more like hey how did you make them feel
how did you connect on that personal
level what were you able to do together
as a community and that's that's
something I'm really trying to you know
lean into which is hard because I'm
still afraid of people's opinions like I
I can't shake that fully like I still
find myself doing body checks and all
these things but I'm getting better at
confronting it and letting that anxiety
kind of course through me and realize
that my fears aren't matching reality
and then it starts to like almost feel
like okay that Demon's starting to like
you know become more of a whisper hmm
like yeah that's really beautifully put
I mean the antidote to the isolation and
the habitat in which the disease can
really uh you know kind of linger is
community right like being with people
being transparent and open and
vulnerable and and trusting letting
people in like so much of it is just
like allowing yourself to open the door
to those people who already want to help
you who've been waiting for you the
whole time and are finally grateful and
thankful that you're giving them that
opportunity and it's hard when you're
stuck in that desperate cycle but you've
walked through that and what I love is
that now like recognizing that and
realizing that that is not only
important but maybe that's the whole
thing you end up starting this trail
series which is is really just uh like
an entrepreneurial external
manifestation of of your recognition of
how important it is to cultivate
community and share the things that you
love and now like you're doing that so
it's one thing to just say I'm going to
start a race series or start a race but
here it's like
it's so wed to your recovery in a really
beautiful and authentic way thanks yeah
yeah
and it was terrifying also have you ever
seen that documentary fire Festival
yes I was 100 that was they were gonna
like do a docu-series on trail Fest how
bad and it was gonna be like people out
in the woods it's kind of like you know
just because you're a trail Runner
doesn't mean that you could be a race
director and create a race it's sort of
like an actor in a movie thinking they
can write direct and produce or you know
like you compete at UTMB that's like
that's like like a guy who shows up for
to do two days on you know the Avengers
movie where there's a million moving
pieces uh and thinking well I can do
this right yeah I can then going and
making your little Indian movie right
but you're you know what a year on the
second you have the second one coming up
yeah yeah it'll be our second one this
September
um and yeah it I mean it was it was an
amazing experience and I definitely
credit all the people involved that help
make it happen you know all my local
Partners in Mammoth and uh it was it was
beautiful but I think what I've really
recognized is as much as as a kid I
dreamed of
being that Superstar sports athlete
naming the Stars you know kind of like
you know being a professional I think
it's a common dream for a lot of kids
you are a professional you know that
right okay it wouldn't matter like if
you had beaten Francois and Killian
there'd still be somebody else like you
wouldn't you would never feel like you
actually there's never that height that
you had set for yourself that's true
touche it um but go ahead sorry no and I
think what I've recognized though is
the impact I really want to have on the
sport or a community is giving other
people those opportunities and I learned
from so many people that came before me
like reading their blogs talking to them
and I I know that the next generation of
Trail Runners are going to supersede
anything Killian Francois myself
Courtney Rory any any of those people
have done and I hope that we just
facilitate and give them opportunities
and help Foster them to achieve those
things with a little bit less of the
side stepping that we may have occurred
because they're gonna you know encounter
some you know kind of fork in the road
and they're going to struggle but
hopefully they can learn from these
experiences and recognize hey you don't
need to change your body to meet sport
it's through training your body will
adapt to what you're doing if you're
nurturing it and taking care of it and
providing you know I love to it and I
think the ultimate Act of
self-compassion would be to fuel your
body properly
um and to actually recover but I I think
those are types of the types of things
that led me into Trail Fest where I see
it as an opportunity to have a platform
to welcome people to The Majestic place
of Mammoth which is absolutely stunning
like it's a beautiful place in
California
um and allow them the opportunity to
then go have this kind of self-discovery
in a majestic place with a very
supportive Community like I mean last
year was amazing we had we had a woman
from the Midwest she showed up had never
been on a mountain in her life she said
that she just heard me talking on a
podcast and thought it was a good idea
so she signed up like and she finished
her first Ultra like we had a guy from
Florida he was training on a treadmill
with an oxygen mask and when he crossed
the line he wept in my arms like he was
just like couldn't believe what he had
just done and I think that's this type
of stuff that really fills me up where I
want to share those experiences with
people what I told all of our Runners
last year was
this is going to be hard you will suffer
like no one get and I mean that's life
right there's no way of avoiding
suffering but what better place than in
a supportive Community like this where
if you do stumble if you do fall if you
fail to make the cut off
we're gonna pick you back up you're
gonna be okay you're gonna have an
amazing weekend learning watching being
inspired by other people and then
hopefully that excites you to go do
another race somewhere right like
removing the veneer of of uh
intimidation from the thing that's
already intimidating and like creating a
welcome environment because they're all
comers yeah I've had periods where I've
definitely thought my life would be
healthier without running which is a
strange thing to say because inherently
running is not bad like running is an
amazing gift to have but my relationship
with it was so so kind of like skewed
and and twisted that it was leading to
unhealthy behaviors and experiences but
running has also changed my life in so
many positive ways and that's what I
want to share with other people and in I
mean I
I am all about the community but I also
love competition like I'm still that you
know athlete and
um like and I I'm not a like I recognize
that we need you know and that is my job
you know like I didn't perform for a
couple years and I basically
was at risk of losing my job you know
and that's a hard thing to swallow but I
think there was that both and you know
you can have celebrate the top level
competition and strive for big audacious
goals and Foster Community individual
wins and recognize that we all can have
something to better ourselves as a
result even if you didn't
top the podium well not only are those
two ands not mutually exclusive they
feed each other because I think the more
that you serve this community of people
through the series that you've created
the more fulfilled you'll become and it
will just make you feel more whole and a
better version of yourself to approach
the competitive side with the races that
you're competing in I mean what is that
like like does that
you're still competitive you're in the
game like how are you thinking about
like the big races that are coming up
like what's on the calendar and what is
your relationship to uh you know the
build up and and your you know how
you're imagining your participation in
them versus what it was like a couple
years ago
it's definitely shifted where as you
said for a while anger drove me and
there have been times where I think can
I even perform if I'm not angry or if I
don't have that like you know built up
you know doubt that I'm trying to prove
everyone wrong and and I think there are
there are and this might be you know
that big question what is your why you
know like in life and Sport I think why
shift they change and mine has
definitely been shifting and changing
and I think I don't I've recognized I
don't need that anger or that doubt or
that insecurity to drive my good
performances I need to lean more into
that community that love that
self-acceptance and that's going to
allow me to self-actualize and and I do
understand that that's a bit you know
maybe you know it's kind of a privilege
and indulgent to be able to like be at
that place but I I'm really thankful
like especially right now like I I
switched sponsors this year right and
that was hard I to be honest I I thought
I was going to grow old with Hoka like I
thought it was going to be you know I
was going to retire and we had a
long-standing relationship and but
several years of underperforming like it
caught up to me you know and and that's
the reality of sport and that's and I
have a great relationship with everyone
there I just saw them a couple weeks ago
at a race and saw my manager and
marketing director and it uh like and I
understood that and going back to
earlier you know I had some friends that
top of their game Meb loses his
sponsorship you know like then he goes
on to win the Olympic trials medal at
the Olympics win New York and no he won
Boston like and so I you know it was
hard though recognizing that like hey
I'm no longer valued but that was
business and my goals my dreams and what
I believe I'm capable are still there
and that's where I'm really thankful you
know with craft coming in when I started
talking to them they had it really
reminded me of like my early days
talking with you know the small you know
the co-founders of Hoka
um and they're excited about the sport
they're kind of creating this Misfit
group of athletes and and inspiring
people that want to change the game you
know from the Footwear to the stories we
tell to the ways we engage with the
community I mean the way they stood by
Tommy was unbelievable like it's amazing
it it just like it reminded me that hey
these are the people I want to surround
myself with and they most importantly
believed in me you know they said hey we
don't think you're done we just think
you've had a tough ring and that's
really what I've like leaned into is my
inner Community you know with with the
brand and with our team and myself and
my my therapist and you know everyone
that's in my circle of recognizing I
still have these big goals I know what
it takes
to you know achieve them and
I'm working towards that and I don't
have to have the self-sensive sense of
humility anymore like for a while I
thought it was bad to say I wanted to
win UTMB so like I'd skirt it and say
I'm just out here to have fun I'm gonna
you know enjoy the vistas and and the
reality is you wouldn't do this type of
training put in the hours see like year
after year or
you know destroy your body through the
Alps
if something wasn't driving you and it's
okay to want to win but I'm separating
that like I don't need to win anymore to
complete myself as a person but I want
to win and I'm training with intention
to win and I believe I can win and that
I will win but I don't need that to
validate myself anymore right and I
think I've never been able to
authentically say that I may have said
it but I didn't believe it like I still
thought my acceptance and love was
contingent on achievement or something
external where and as you said there's
never enough like that's massive growth
you know that that I mean in this
evolution of of your why and how you
define your why and what motivates you
as you pivot away from these old uh
behaviors and patterns that don't serve
you into this you know different more
you know nourishing way that involves
the trail series and the community and
like understanding that you don't have
to earn love and all of that like you
don't get the dopamine hits that like
anger is going to give you or these
other spikes that you know you've come
to rely on over the years and have like
mistakenly associated with performance
but what you're doing is building a
really solid foundation for a healthier
approach a healthier approach to being a
competitive athlete and you are taking
out an insurance policy on your
longevity but it takes
a while to build that Foundation right
so you're still you're still you haven't
emerged from the foundation stage yet to
actually show people what you're capable
of which I think makes it a very
exciting time for you and that's where
it would have been really easy to
default where
dropped out of utme the last two years
again like last year I had covid finally
caught me after two I'm not a monthly
relapse into my food you know yep idiocy
just just so I can extract this one
performance and make sure that I'm
holding on to these sponsors and then
I'll go back to the recoveries and then
it'll be fine yeah and I'm really proud
that I didn't do that and and I think
it's just that re like affirming and a
reminder that just because you do
everything right doesn't mean you're
actually going to get the outcome you
wanted like life isn't fair like you're
not going to get what you deserve but
you keep showing up you know you keep
trying you keep giving the effort and at
some point I am a believer that things
will work out in a positive way but you
have to go through a lot of [__] to get
there you know and and that's where I
love that saying I think it came from
Vanilla Sky you know the suite is never
a sweet without the sour and it's like
we all have sour in our life you know
and instead of trying to numb that sour
you know let it fuel you into something
else because once you get the sweet it's
going to be really it's still a pretty
new sport right and we've there's been a
lot of growing pains and you know it's
sort of emerging out of this phase of
dirt baggery into like real money and
you know we saw Iron Man take over UTMB
and like these are big changes and I'm
sure not everyone's happy about them
um but
they're a reflection of growing interest
uh in the sport more people
participating in them
uh money coming in sponsor like all of
this stuff right and and meanwhile
um athletes getting more and more
sophisticated and Savvy about how to
race and train so
prior or in maybe the the the the flight
or the generation that preceded yours
there were a lot of people who would
come they would arrive on the scene and
they would just destroy everybody and be
unbelievable and then
would be completely unable to ever
replicate those performances and and are
never to be heard from again only a
couple outliers had any type of
longevity in the sport
um now we see you know there's Killian
and I mean Courtney people like that I'm
interested in in you know why you think
they're so good or so much better than
everyone else but you know what are you
learning about what's required to have
that kind of longevity or to maintain an
elite level of performance over the
course of you know a respectable amount
of time as opposed to a flash in the pan
and also as a kind of side note to that
we saw what happened with Anton krupika
right like he he was like he was the
dude Gone Forever back like had an
incredible performance last year like
that's very cool like I think that you
know just because maybe to your point
like you've had a downturn
um you know there's still sweet to be
mined on the other side of sour yep in
Indian endurance Endeavor or Sports
I feel that the like the patient will
ultimately be rewarded like it's
consistency is key that is the under
appreciated skill set in endurance like
it's about stacking hours season after
season year after year and keep showing
up you know I I talked to a close friend
one time and I said you know or you kind
of asked a similar thing like you know
what sets people apart and I like my
response was it's hard to beat someone
when they don't know when to stop
showing up like is that like Rocky
Balboa like you just true in anything
like you just you gotta grind right and
uh and I think that's something I really
hope to do in our sport is set the Next
Generation up
to have more consistency and have
the ability to not only self-actualize
but avoid burnout
you know and so if we can do that
collectively as a community I think we
will have won so that if you know your
kids want to get into ultra running they
know that the healthy way to do that is
to nurture their body or if they want to
get into Marathon or sport or anything
like you know don't try to manipulate
your body to mirror some idealistic
version you've seen of X because you
don't know what's actually behind that
like I mean if someone was modeling me
they were modeling after a very sick
unhealthy person like and I wouldn't
want that to happen you know so I I hope
that we changed those conversations and
then I think through that discourse and
discussion we can get more people to
basically adhere to you know the values
and Norms that are going to allow for
healthy like relationship with a sport
and that's going to just trickle down
into all aspects and make the community
stronger
um I I think that's probably you know
going to be the most important thing and
and you you mentioned the you know big
players coming in and kind of you know
maybe changing in the face of the sport
and that's happening change is hard like
it uh growth is not does not come easy
it I remember back in school
um you undergrad we we had to read this
book um uh omnivores dilemma sure and
yeah you would know right you know a
little bit about nutrition
um it's uh and
like I believe he talks about like you
know our choices like we vote with our
our dollars with our choices and I feel
like the same is true for our communion
sport you know people are always going
to show up and support purchase and
align themselves with people and Brands
and companies they share similar values
and we have collectively a lot of power
to do that and I think our group of
Trail Runners can do that so like if we
don't like things are going a certain
way you know we just can make those
choices on our own
um but uh I think that I am excited to
see where it goes because as we get more
opportunities for athletes I think we're
going to see you know even more
Transcendent performances like we're
going to get more Courtney's and gyms
out there in the next Generation as we
mentioned it's inevitable in the same
way
you know if you look over the history of
Iron Man or Triathlon the people that
would win were people who were really
good at one of the three and if you
happen to be good at two of the three
you were like you know beyond you know
so you would be you know a marathon
runner or a Collegiate track and field
athlete
um could do well now you have to be
unbelievable at all three yeah and
that's not a guarantee of anything and
now in the world of ultra running we're
seeing you Walmsley like people that are
Olympic trials qualifiers in Marathon
going into trail running like you're
only going to see more and more Elite
performers especially when the money
comes in like you know it's like if
you're an Elite Track and Field athlete
or Marathon or why are you gonna [__]
around in the trail world when there's
no money and you could just get hurt or
whatever there's too much risk involved
but you know that's changing and I think
it's only going to attract a higher
caliber of athlete and who's who's
approaching it you know not from uh well
I eat granola bars and do whatever to
like being very precise and intentional
about what they're doing yeah you know I
think there's a lot of room for growth
here oh for sure so I mean that's where
I feel lucky that I came up when I did
because if I had been this athlete and
this goes back to even high school like
I wasn't recruited out of high school to
go to college I walked on I wasn't an
All-American in college
I left without that Accolade that every
Collegiate athlete wants but I kept
going and like I just didn't give up on
myself but I think with the sport like
and I was fortunate because like when I
was in high school we aren't where we
are 20 years later in so such good
guidance for high school kids like the
level of training they're getting is
next level and we're going to see that
in trail running if I'd come up into
trail running 10 years from now I
couldn't have gotten away with all the
[__] I did with starving myself and not
treating my body well and I hope that
people recognize that the only way to
really self-actualize or get the best
out of yourself is to do these things
properly you know no shortcuts you know
it's not there aren't any hacks out
there that are going to get you there
like a hack is the quickest way to get
you on the injury list like you're gonna
end up with stress fractures you know a
whole host of things and there are times
where I wonder like was all of that
abuse I did to my body over the last 15
years like is it finally catching up on
me it's like maybe
and if that's the case like I had a good
run and like I'm not gonna like let that
deter me from what I want to do next
like but I'm confident that that isn't
the case like I think that that is my
superpower is the durability and I just
have been fortunate to have messed up so
many times and still had Second Chances
so that's kind of yeah I get it yeah I
get it I think like you're describing
like oh if I if I starve myself or do
this what this thing that I know is not
in my long-term best interest but
probably will help me short term is the
short-term game and when you're like
young and you're a Gunner and that race
is everything you'll take that bargain
every time and I'm sure tons of athletes
do that it's like who cares like never
sport I'll deal with the whatever my
bone density you know 10 years from now
I don't care about that what I'm what I
care about is what's going to happen in
six weeks yeah so it's really hard to
overcome that especially with you know
younger people who have a hard time
thinking long term about anything like
these are decisions that you know start
to make sense when you're in the
Twilight of your career and you're
trying to you know keep going right
we're in that rocking chair moment where
we can just like reflect on everything
yeah yeah yeah but that's where like in
the social media age we are rewarded
with instant gratification
so like undoing or not undoing but like
acknowledging that's one path not the
only path and learning to pleasure delay
I think is really important to instill
with anybody in any Endeavor like
because that's where the greatest you
know benefit's gonna come sure is if you
can
display some emotional control
to then at some point reap the rewards
and I think a good way to kind of I want
to close this with
um a little bit of guidance and help for
either people who are in the midst of
suffering from some version of of what
you've gone through and are and the
alarm bells are going off in their minds
because they're relating to what you
have to share or people who have people
in their life that they are confused
around how to best help them and for the
teachers and the coaches and the parents
to understand how to look out for this
and what the warning signs are so if
you're you know a a basketball coach or
a track and field coach or you're a
seventh grade teacher or you're a parent
whose kids are now adolescents and
you're noticing hey this thing around
food doesn't look quite so right like
what have you learned about what to look
out for and once you have a sense that
maybe something might be awry like how
do you
navigate how do you address that with
that person how you know what is the way
and this is obviously not and there's no
easy way to answer this but you know I'm
sure there's a lot of people out there
who are like I know this person needs
help I don't know how to help them what
should I do
that's another two hour podcast a week
ago can you set hours on this I think
Lindsay was out questions so I'm good I
got my coffee still
um I think it's important to to let
people know that you love them
like that's that's at the heart of it
like you are there you love them you
know for who they are
um you aren't going to be the one
responsible to fix someone and that's
what I think a lot of us try to do is we
want to be the the fixer
um and in reality with anyone that might
be suffering from something like they
need to be they need autonomous
autonomously make that decision to to
seek help or get treatment
um but you need to show that you support
them not enable them but support them
and I think then it's about
collaboratively reaching out to people
that are the professionals you know so
if you're a coach and you see this kind
of behavior starting in someone that
you're worried about you know I think
bringing in a professional to help would
be good you know getting you know the
the school psychologist or the
nutritionist like but it I think it's
important to really not approach people
as you're doing something wrong you need
to come to them like from a place of
love and let them know that hey like you
know we're worried about this and let's
you know talk about what's going on
because I think conversation is the re
the root of everything like I wish I had
been strong enough to have conversations
with people when I was growing up or in
college or with Lindsay early on like
a myriad of reasons I didn't but I think
not talking allowed me to basically
build unchecked narratives in my head
that just ruminated got deeper The Roots
got deeper and eventually like it just
you know started to strangle everything
but talking in conversation also aren't
light switches you didn't grow up in a
household where you learned how to do
that or where that was modeled or
practiced so if there isn't a habit or a
practice or an environment where trust
and kind of open dialogue is already
kind of in place that takes a lot of
time to build and establish you can't
just you know come to somebody who's
never who has no who's not used to that
and say it's time to talk and expect
that person to be open with you yeah no
not at all and I think that's where you
just have to approach like all these
conversations or people kind of with the
grace of recognizing meet them where
they are don't expect a quick fix you
know it's not a light switch we're
dealing with dimmer switches you know
it's going to be a slow up and down and
that's the thing with recovery is we
expect it to be linear and it's anything
but right like I'm sure you have felt
that or you you know if and it's it's
very circuitous and it's you know what
we think it looks like is you know this
A A to B you know vertical line or you
know like you know going up on the graph
but it's it's just convoluted it's
messed up and being kind to yourself or
others when they aren't making the
progress we expect because each person's
time frame is going to be different
um but I think I think you know that's
probably important but yeah having the
conversations is not going to be easy
and that's the the hardest thing like
I've seen people suffer and I can't
reach out to talking because I'm afraid
I don't have the right words and I think
that's what prevents a lot of us from
doing a lot of things is the fear of not
having the right thing to say and
sometimes just being there or saying
something is what someone needs to hear
yeah it uh I think I don't know it I I
really try to tell myself like you know
stop measuring and start living you know
his Life's too short to count all your
Cheerios you know it's like you really
need to get out of out of that model and
and realize that you know the beauty
that is in life is if you're actually in
the game like you can't just be a
spectator in your own life and like
window shop while everyone else is
feasting on I know the you know the
goods of what being alive is and and I
think you know anyone that might be
suffering or has questions like you know
just know that the ultimate Act of
Courage would be just to talk to someone
like and and it's never going to be as
bad as you think it is like like we said
no one's watching us like
no one well people might be watching us
on YouTube right now but uh it's you
know no one cares The Way We Care you
know I think that's very well said yeah
I mean obviously certainly if you're
listening or watching to this and and
and you're having a sense that that
maybe you need to talk to somebody about
your own behavior
it would be absolutely key to reach out
to somebody you trust somebody who you
feel uh will receive you with Grace and
not judgment I mean the Judgment piece I
think is huge but you're not going to be
able to solve the problem in your head
despite what you think and it's not
going to go away because you're pushing
it down uh the only solution is going to
come by
raising your hand inviting people in and
not only asking for help but receiving
that help when people offer to help you
and that is much harder than trying to
you know grit your teeth and figure it
out yourself yeah because you know well
if I figure it out myself then I don't
have to tell anybody about it right
that's the thing and I think if you're
somebody who's bearing witness to
somebody suffering whether you're a
parent or a friend or a colleague or a
teacher or coach it can be very
confusing because if you don't have any
personal familiarity with this it defies
logic why can't they just fix this or
why don't they stop doing that thing
can't they see and I can see what they
need to do and they can't
and so with that like when you're when
you're kind of thinking of it in that
context
when you approach that person you're
going to be coming at them like pretty
aggressively or with a lot of judgment
or confusion and that's going to put
that person on their heels and defensive
so you got to find a way to Broach it in
a compassionate way
um you know by draining it of any
judgment and and just coming at it with
love and curiosity and to your point
like not being codependent I'm not here
to like enable you I'm not going to keep
your secret and you know maybe I can't
even be your friend right now but like
when you're ready I love you and when
you're ready for help like I want you to
I want me to be your first call like
this and it's it's hard man you know it
is and when people who care about the
people who are suffering they're
suffering themselves and they can't help
that person unless they're taking care
of themselves so you know whether it's
Al-Anon are finding their own Community
with people who have you know navigated
that same thing I think becomes really
key that's spot on and I love what you
said it's that like non-judgmental
awareness of the situation like you
don't have to place judgment on what
they're doing you could say I don't even
need you to stop I'm not telling you to
stop no I'm just saying like I know
what's up yeah yeah exactly like and
because that's going to disarm people
like
all of us are conditioned where if if
you come in I'm gonna immediately like
you know
be resistant and you know lie my way out
of something you know because there is
that shame component that you're wrapped
up in and that will lead you to do
things you don't want to do
um but I I think that you know coming in
with that non-judgmental kind of
awareness of the situation and then also
educating yourself you know I think a
lot of that you know the misconception
of what OCD or eating disorders are like
with OCD is like oh I'm compulsive like
you know like I like to arrange my pen
certain ways and like so it it kind of
gets maybe reduced into like something
that's more like a personality trait
versus like an actual disorder and I
think just educating ourselves on you
know this is something that's actually
leading people to suffer like it's
intrusive it's unwelcomed and it's
debilitating and Progressive and
Progressive like and what we said
earlier if you think about anorexia
nervosa which is one of the major Eating
Disorders is the has the highest rate of
mortality out of any mental health like
illness that's scary like so it's not
just a oh yeah we all overeat or we all
have like problems with food it's like
yes that's true but let's educate
ourselves that some people really are
suffering and I think that's the
important piece where like then we can
come to them with compassion it's not
just oh yeah like I don't like how my
legs look in the mirror or you know how
my my shirt fit today like because all
those are true and and I think it's just
recognizing that okay like
this is a serious thing and not to redo
like you know belittle it um or you know
kind of reduce it in in your mind uh I
think that's a huge step because then
the person that's suffering will feel a
little more welcomed that okay like you
actually understand you know it's not
like oh yeah like I I count my calories
it's like well did you count 300 times
today yeah it's like did you win that
game like if you want to go to war over
like this yeah yeah so it's kind of like
you know but it's all a specimen I loved
what you said earlier it's like it's
about us managing our feelings and our
triggers because we're not going to live
in a world and I don't want a world
where everyone's tiptoeing around and
like they can't say certain things you
know I we shall be respectful but I need
to manage myself in the world that's an
open environment that people are gonna
say do and act in different ways and I
can't expect them to always like coddle
me right yeah I just okay if I eat in
front of you yeah exactly like so it's
about like finding that balance point
but like just being respective of where
people are yeah and and and understand
that it's
it's a disorder it's a disease it's not
the person like yep decoupling the
Identity or that person you know from
the behavior I think is really important
and realizing that it's a coping
strategy born out of a feeling of being
less than or out of control or being
incapable of of giving yourself the
level of self-love that that you know we
all deserve right and that recovery is
that Journey towards self-acceptance and
and self-love as the antidote to to that
darkness and it can feel like I'm broken
I'm the one the thing that's wrong not
acknowledge that oh I do have this
illness and it's kind of like the
computer is glitching we don't just
throw the computer away like you upload
the software better you know you just
like give it a patch and it's like we
just gotta like you know kind of work on
the you know how we're dealing with
things like but I think that prevents
people from asking for help or mention
because it feels like
they're broken if you knew just how bad
I am and how broken I am and how Beyond
repair the situation is like that's the
mentality and it's I mean I'll be honest
letting go of the reassurance seeking
behavior is very scary like I've had
times where I don't know where I am in
the world it's so unsettling because I'm
I'm trying to actively fight whatever
Behavior was going to reassure me that
it was okay and and that's a terrifying
thing so it's like you're caught in this
massive
storm out in the ocean and you were had
this shitty little life raft and like
arm floaties and you were terrified but
you felt some sort of comfort with your
little rafting your arm floaties
compared to when you have the calm open
C and you're all alone and there's
nothing else there yeah like what am I
supposed to do with all this like
Serenity I'd rather have the noise in my
head and like grip on white knuckling
these little things then that but
eventually you recognize that the
calmness and the serenity is a state you
can live in and Trust
but as you said it's going to take time
and
also it's going to take resources and
it's not it's not easy like to get those
resources like when I left my job as a
full-time therapist I lost my health
insurance so the best thing for me to
deal with some of these anxiety inducing
things was leaving that full-time
employment and by doing so I lost access
to my Healthcare right you couldn't pay
I couldn't it wasn't recovery resources
that you needed yeah which you know that
was a that was a shame that's [__] up
like yeah that sucked like and I mean
again I'm I'm at a place where I mean I
I had two other careers going a pro
athlete and a race director like you
know building something so I was really
like burning myself out with three
things just filling the void but
it shouldn't be that way I wish we had
access to resources that you know
because
people are struggling like and and it's
always going to be that way but there is
like you said everything is impermanent
and there was something I came across in
um and my recovery is the term wabi-sabi
and it's this Japanese philosophy taken
from nature that everything is
impermanent imperfect and incomplete and
I think it's a beautiful way to kind of
look at ourselves our situations the
world
things are imperfect
they are you know impermanent it will
pass and we'd know that in Ultras you
could be in the lowest low you've ever
had and somehow you went 70 more miles
after that
because you didn't give in yet you know
it'll pass but then it's also incomplete
like our recoveries aren't complete you
know our our careers our relationships
and I think just like me leaning into
that and accepting that oh like someone
that wanted control on everything
someone that like was tied up in it like
perfectionism and thinking that that was
the way to you know Salvation or you
know being loved or accepted and
recognize that everything is impermanent
imperfect and complete like it helped me
kind of like start to like settle in to
the muck and just be like oh okay like I
can live with that like you know because
I'm chasing this this figment of
something that doesn't exist it's it's
theoretical professional if it does
yourself it's real but it doesn't exist
yeah it is it's like a math problem like
anyway yeah so and there's a relief in
that yeah but also
discomfort and yeah and that's what we
we like to numb ourselves yeah Rich like
we yeah but I I have really learned and
I continue to remind myself that like
learning to let go is far more powerful
than holding on and that that's not easy
but I'm trying to let go of more and
more things and trust and that's a very
counter-intuitive uh edict in and of
itself but to tell a hard driving very
competitive athlete or business person
or just Ambush ambitious person in
general that the better way is in the
surrender and the Letting Go you might
as well be speaking you know Mongolian
like it just doesn't it's like what are
you talking about like the whole reason
I'm here and and what fuels me is my
ability to like
double down on that self-will and hold
on even more tightly and push push push
push so the subtlety or the you know the
kind of being in that state where you're
untethering yourself from results and
you know floating in that calm body of
water is like yeah it's like being on
Mars like that is not you know that it
takes a long time to really understand
what that means and to and to grok the
fact that it's not about
um
it's not about like giving up yeah it's
just tapping into a more powerful and
more sustainable fuel source that not
only will lead you exactly towards the
same things that you're ambitious about
although your goals may change you know
you can't be ready for that uh but but
also yeah you'll be able to do it with
with joy and with others and all of
these things that you have decided are
are indulgences or distractions totally
and that's I think that was key what you
said is the you don't have to like it
like you know it's that like
acknowledging this the radical
acceptance idea of hey this is what's
occurring you don't have to like it but
what are you going to do about it you
know what's that next step and and I
think that's where people get stuck
sometimes
um but uh well that's why you know the
universe is wired to you know create
these bottoms so you can have these
reckonings in these realizations which
are gifts right like so you crashed into
the wall and now you're on the other
side and you're you've had you're like
oh my God and now we're talking about it
but the fact that somebody listening to
this might be struck and short of
hitting their own bottom is going to say
I'm going to do that like that's
unlikely it's probably not going to
happen you know you have to it's an
experiential thing you might have to
suffer a certain kind of pain that's
different than the pain you suffer when
you're running an ultra marathon a
psychic pain a spiritual emotional pain
and uh and those tend to be levers and
motivators to do things a different way
yeah for sure without a doubt like and I
think I think you're spot on like the
like you know you have to go through
that resistance
um and
I don't know thinking about running 100
miles through the Alps doesn't seem as
scary or daunting as like living with
your own thoughts when you're like
really in that right like which is the
source of all of man's suffering right
of course his inability to sit alone for
five minutes we're gonna fill that void
with something but yeah it's well I'm
gonna go like the the suffering in the
mountains is really just an elaborate
distraction from having to sit alone
with yourself for a couple minutes and
how often do people now take their phone
or their podcast or whatever while you
know a lot of people will be on their
run or their bike listening to this like
and something I've actually done that I
think is really great for where I'm at
is I've unplugged when I go run
no more stimulus I was almost using that
like I forgot what running felt like
because I was like there was always
something I was trying to get out of it
outside of and like I was just over
stimulating and I went for a run and I
literally was just listening to my
breath
my foot falls the birds and it was it
like reminded me of me as a kid running
it's like oh like that's what I love
about running like moving through space
quickly you know kind of feeling
effortless and floating and you describe
the Flow State just a little bit ago
like you know letting everything go
Letting Go the control not thinking
getting rid of that analysis by
paralysis that's where you're going to
produce your best work whatever it is if
you're an artist or an athlete or a uh
you know if you're in in medicine or I
feel like you do have to let go that
control stop thinking and Trust the
process well to be continued man I can't
wait to see what you're you're gonna uh
you're gonna manifest and do I'm excited
about the trail series I'm excited about
uh the performances on The Horizon but
more than anything just this message
that you're carrying has a very uh you
know kind of
important vibration to it uh you're an
amazing you know vehicle to speak about
this thing and and my goal for this
podcast really honestly is to is to just
make more people aware of what you uh
went through so others don't have to and
for that message to Ripple out and
transcend Beyond like the trail
Community to a larger a larger you know
population of people because I I do
think as I said at the outset
um
it's important when when men speak up
about this because I I do think that
there are just so many men out there who
are suffering in Silence with this
because there isn't a culture of
permissiveness around talking about it
so I applaud you
um for the courage and the the
vulnerability that you've demonstrated
in in you know kind of shouldering the
responsibility like in a public service
announcement way to talk about this
stuff uh so it was really cool and um I
appreciate your openness man thank you
yeah sure and thanks for sharing those
stories because it it makes a difference
someone out there will hear
one of your podcasts and it'll say it'll
save them so yeah we'll see man all I do
is I put it out there and then it's up
to them right yeah I'm surrendering I am
surrendering this podcast in the world
Tim wait can we do the
we're gonna do it we're not there yet I
was gonna I was this was like my big
operation did I jump the gun yeah like
his is like I'm I'm gonna softball I'm
throwing you I'm tossing you the
softball for the plug like where do you
want you're on Instagram you got the
like what are the URLs where do you want
people to go yeah I'm sure people are
gonna wanna learn more about
um the uh Mammoth trail series in
September so where where can they find
out more about that uh
mammothtrailfest.com would be it we're
it's pretty cool we we have over a
thousand people signed up for this year
um and they're only there aren't too
many spots left so if anyone's
interested in joining they they should
get on it um and uh and someday I'll
learn how to you know do thoughtful
merch but uh right now we don't really
have much but tag but yeah yeah we don't
do that either it's like do people
really want coffee mugs I guess they do
as I take a sip out of my branded coffee
bag that I can't sell because this is
the only one we have but I I would just
encourage people if they were interested
like and they they aren't gonna run like
just come join the party like we're
looking for like what we're terming the
Sierra Soiree like it's just going to be
this big Gathering of our community at
the end of September before the snow
hits the Sierra and if you can't make it
go out to one of your local Trail events
like volunteer join in just see how
powerful it is watching people overcome
you know their doubts their fears these
incredible you know endurance Feats and
and just go be part of it I think it's
going to make all this a little bit
better so you know I I would really just
encourage people to get out there and
join the drill to me is the best place
in the world so cool man yeah right on
thank you thanks again for sure I'm
gonna let you now now here it is you do
you do it peace plants